kate and i are the funniest contestants
but never
have i ever what
oh this is this is already very weird
i'm joel mccann
this is kate flannery i feel like this
is all usable
we're gonna play never have i ever which
i have never played in my life
and you have you i have never played
never have i ever but uh
you know what um this is the i've had
some green beer um let's see what
happens let's go let's do it
[Music]
all my answers are going to relate to
community
all my office office answers
i can't drink in all my own all my
office
all my answers are gonna pertain to the
show the office
which she was on
never have i ever pranked a co-star on
set
neither have i yeah
nope they're so disappointed the
producers are like
well we just don't think we're sorry we
had a lot of laughs but they were all
scripted
yeah we didn't have time for that we
were busy
we had some of the best writers
oh there was that one time yeah
i accidentally i set the set on fire it
was hilarious
[Music]
never have i ever called my co-star by a
wrong name
no i knew them very well i spent
tons of time with them so yeah
i i never did on the office but on stage
with jane lynch
i called her joan a couple times
oh never have i ever pretended that i
was sick so i didn't have to work
no i yeah i know i never did that
i'm sorry i wish i had i have never
pretended to be sick so i could get out
of work never
i would never do that no because you
know like when you're on a tv show
you get like i'm on a tv show this is
great yeah it's like better than
watching tv yeah it's like you're
getting paid to do the thing that you
always wanted to do when you're on a
show
stay home and better you wouldn't
actually want it do it
yeah yeah i never do that all right this
is my favorite game
this is so good kate's my new favorite
person as well
[Music]
never have i ever arrived to work
hungover
[Music]
do i have to do how many times i hunt
how about just one okay sorry
how many times did you do well there's a
lot of award shows we had to work the
next day i'm just saying
yeah no i would say yeah there was
always like late nights
that you were doing stuff for non-show
but i've never
i never came in like sick or
nothing like that maybe not like me but
i was throwing up
i was always so worried i wasn't gonna
get like sleep
we are not that this wasn't like that
70s show or the oc where everybody's
18 years old and they can party all
night
this was i was in my mid-30s and i had
kids
so it was like busy times and i was just
afraid of getting
fired at any moment so i just yeah
i was drunk clarkson i didn't want to
get fired
today a little bit yeah
never have i ever lied to my boss
uh i'm trying to think of dan was my
boss
and no i never lied to him i mean i
don't know what i would be you know
you're wired
i'm just saying this is happening i was
i was like refused
jeff i i don't
know no i don't think so i'm trying to
think of i would never
only when i called in sick or hungover
this so so we're tied at nine right yes
so you never lie
i'm you never left i never lie i never
led to my shirt never lied to
greg daniels i never lied to ricky
gervais even though he was never around
okay well have you lied to kelly
clarkson
[Laughter]
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever